Jessica Cox was born without arms due to a rare, nongenetic birth defect.
But this hasn't held her back from driving a car, gaining a black belt in Taekwondo,...
...playing the piano, scuba diving...
...and becoming the world's first licensed armless pilot.
Naturally, people saw the fact that I didn't have arms as a limiting factor.
But I was there to prove them wrong.
Now, she travels the world as a motivational speaker with her husband Patrick.
If I had to describe Jessica in three words,...
...it would be kind, positive and unstoppable.
In 2008, her determination paid off...
...when she became the first licensed armless pilot in the world.
Three years, three different airplanes, three different flight instructors,...
...80 hours of flying in three different states, I was a certified pilot.
It was a long ordeal.